breaking news we're going to speak to
kate mccann our political correspondent
about events in the house of commons in
just a moment but first we had a
statement in from the rspca now this
concerns a story you may well be
familiar with and concerning the west
ham football player kurt zuma who over
the weekend was filmed kicking his pet
cat the video was filmed by his brother
it was put on social media and it came
into the public domain uh over the last
48 hours well the rspca have released
this statement saying the two cats uh
the two cats owned by kurt zuma are now
in rspca care our priority is and has
always been the well-being of these cats
they've been taken for a checkup at vets
and then will remain in our care while
the investigation continues we're
regretful we are grateful rather to
anyone who expressed their concern for
these cats we were dealing with this
issue before the video went viral online
and are leading the investigation we
continue to investigate so we cannot
comment further at this time so that is
the rspca
taking away
the west ham player kurt zuma's two pet
cats this is after he was filmed
kicking one of them